[Música]
[Aplausos]
las personas miremos muy poco al cielo
claro es normal del día al sol resulta
cenador y de noche de sencillamente pues
estamos durmiendo tampoco es que haya
muchas amenazas que caigan del cielo que
deben captar nuestra atención y mantener
nuestros sentidos alerta en esa
dirección y quizás es por eso que la
evolución ha ido configurando la
orientación de nuestros ojos en un eje
horizontal para así tener una visión
panorámica que es la que maximiza la
información acerca de posibles
depredadores que puedan aguardar en
nuestro entorno en el horizonte
es inevitable que la visión horizontal
del mundo haya afectado a nuestra forma
de entender la realidad
por eso los rectángulos horizontales
iguales resultan tan atractivos y quizás
también por ese motivo mirar al cielo
nos resulte tan extraño tan misterioso
tan tan ajeno a lo cotidiano
qué pasaría si hubiese peligros en el
cielo que requiriera nuestra atención
bueno resulta que eso es lo que les pasa
a las iguanas que resulta que son unas
presas de los halcones yo esto no lo
sabía
la evolución a lo largo del tiempo les
ha ido dotando de un tercer ojo eso que
veis en la parte superior de su cráneo
que parece una escama un poco más clara
en realidad es un sistema óptico muy
rudimentario para mirar al cielo no se
puede orientar fácilmente ni le permite
enfocar para generar imágenes definidas
pero sí le permite detectar una sombra
que algo se cierne sobre su cabeza
tener dos ojos no solo nos sirve para
tener un panorama más amplio de nuestro
entorno sino que también nos permite
medir distancia a los objetos con
nuestros dos ojos tenemos dos
perspectivas completamente distintas de
la realidad ligeramente en realidad
están separadas sólo por unos
centímetros y si hacemos la diferencia
entre la imagen de uno y otro nuestro
cerebro es capaz de sacar una enorme
fuente de información acerca de la
tridimensionalidad del mundo con
nuestros dos ojos de hecho podemos
triangular las distancias hasta objetos
que están incluso a una decena de metros
pensad lo útil que es eso para un simio
arbóreo por ejemplo que tiene que igual
saltar de la copa de un árbol al otro
con sus dos ojos puede estimar y
triangular la distancia de esa rama y
así dar ese salto con confianza sin
tener que caer al suelo de la selva que
es un lugar muy oscuro y por lo tanto
muy peligroso pero bueno lo de los ojos
no sólo es una cuestión de que tengamos
dos importa mucho la separación que haya
entre ellos cuanto más separado mejor
triangulamos le importa que cada ojo sea
capaz de medir ángulos muy pequeños vale
eso es lo que llamamos resolución
angular
resolución ocular
hace unos años paseando por el pasillo
de mi facultad me topé con un cartel que
llamaba para unas becas estudiantiles
para la agencia espacial europea
claro yo creo que mucha gente no se fijó
aquel día en ese cartel y yo desde luego
no esperaba más que jugar un poco a la
ruleta a la suerte cuando cuando me lo
planteé pero bueno pero jugué y envié mi
esquelético currículum de estudiante y
tuve la suerte de que al otro lado
estaba este hombre jesús myles que
también se la jugó la verdad y decidió
contratar a un simple estudiante de
grado con apenas experiencia laboral
jesús me dio la oportunidad de trabajar
en una línea de investigación puntera en
el campo de la astrofísica estelar con
los datos de un o de una máquina muy
sofisticada muy sensible un instrumento
que rinde gloria al trabajo del ser
humano como diría quizás maiakovski
esta máquina es gaia
imaginad que en vez de tener mis ojos
separados unos pocos centímetros los
estuvieran separados 300 millones de
kilómetros a través del sistema solar
en vez de percibir mi entorno inmediato
en tres dimensiones podría entender las
distancias a escala interestelar eso es
justo lo que hace galla gaia es un
telescopio espacial lo que significa que
está fuera de la tierra está orbitando
al sol como lo haría a nuestro planeta
no tenemos dos gallas así que lo que
hacemos es esperar a que la sonda se
mueva unos cuantos millones de
kilómetros cada seis meses y adquiera
esa otra perspectiva se convierta en ese
segundo ojo y con eso es con lo que
podemos triangular pero además de esto
gaia no sólo necesita una línea base que
decimos muy grande para triangular sino
que necesita medir en ángulos
extremadamente pequeños gaia es capaz de
detectar las 100 millones y aparte de un
grado un grado que ya es un ángulo
pequeño imaginaos la acción millonésima
si una persona tuviera este poder en sus
ojos podría percibir la esfera de un
reloj de pulsera apoyado sobre la
superficie de la luna a más de 300.000
kilómetros de distancia
la estructura rígida que sostienen los
espejos y sensores de gaia tiene que
estar térmicamente controlada para que
fluctúa ciones de milésimas o centésimas
de grado no dilate ni contraigan todo el
aparataje óptico y de salyn en el
sistema un ordenador de abordo clasifica
y cataloga miles de estrellas cada
minuto a día de hoy que haya registrado
los brillos los colores las posiciones
incluso en algunos casos las distancias
de más de 1.800 millones de estrellas de
nuestra galaxia la vía láctea
imaginad por un momento que dedicáramos
un segundo de atención a cada uno de
estos sistemas estelares y pensar de
cada uno con sus planetas con sus lunas
con sus asteroides sus cometas sus
procesos físico-químicos sus historias
geológicas sólo un segundo a cada
sistema estelar entonces necesitaréis 57
años para poder echarle un simple
vistazo a la plétora de mundos
escrutados por los ojos de gaia a día de
hoy
he tenido la oportunidad de encabezar
junto a jesús un equipo internacional
para la confección de un mapa estelar de
nuestra galaxia es el más preciso hasta
la fecha y con gaia podemos hacerlo en
3-d
esto que veis aquí es una representación
científico artística digamos verosímil
del aspecto que tiene nuestra galaxia es
un conjunto de 400.000 millones de
estrellas cuestionadas por la gravedad y
organizadas en una estructura de disco
plano en la zona central bulliciosa
llena de estrellas viejas salen unos
brazos unos patrones en forma de brazos
espirales a través de todo el disco
nuestra galaxia mide 180 mil años-luz
esto significa de la luz tarda 180 mil
años en atravesar la extensión de este
monstruoso sistema físico
por cierto nuestra galaxia es una de
millones de millones de galaxias que
creemos contiene el universo observable
el sistema solar el sol y sus planetas
no está localizado en el centro en la
zona de esta bulliciosa interesante está
lejos a unas decenas de miles de años
luz del centro en el disco en una región
que carl sagan llamaba a los suburbios
de la galaxia desde nuestra perspectiva
en este planeta confinados en el disco
galáctico los brazos de la vía láctea se
solapan en el cielo nocturno formando
una franja de estrellas difusa y lejana
que nos envuelve y que corta la bóveda
celeste
superpuesta sobre este modelo
artístico de la vía láctea podéis ver ya
nuestro mapa estelar cada punto luminoso
que estáis viendo en esta representación
es una estrella que hemos catalogado
minuciosamente y no son todas las
estrellas de gaia esto es una selección
muy particular porque son estrellas que
brillan especialmente esas son muy
luminosas y porque esto es importante
pues porque se convierten en excelentes
trabajadores de la geografía galáctica
son como faros marcando las costas
remotas de nuestra galaxia entre las
cosas que hemos encontrado está esta
sobre densidad de estrellas a la que
hemos llamado el espolón de cc.oo es un
puente hecho de estrellas que conectan
los brazos de perseo y el brazo de orión
que es el brazo espiral por cierto en el
que se sitúa el sistema solar el espolón
de cc.oo mide unos 8 mil años-luz y se
encuentra en una región que en un
principio creíamos que estaría vacía no
esperábamos encontrar nada aquí pero lo
que más nos sorprendió es cuando lo
miramos de lado porque nos dimos cuenta
que el espolón de cefeo no está
exactamente en el disco de la galaxia
está ligeramente por encima a unos 300
años luz por encima de la media el plano
de la vía láctea y esto es raro porque
la galaxia tiene mucha gravedad del
disco es capaz de atraer con fuerza a
las estrellas así que como han llegado a
estar tan arriba sobre el disco todas
las estrellas del espolón de cc.oo acaso
han sido catapultada si han sido
lanzadas desde una región de la galaxia
de forma sincronizada para llegar todas
ahí y que las veamos nosotros ahora
bueno esto es poco probable y es poco
probable porque este tipo de estrellas
en realidad viven poco en escalas de
tiempo geológicas claro y eso significa
que no han podido hacer grandes viajes a
través de la galaxia no han podido
llegar ahí a lo largo de sus breves
vidas
así que se tienen que haber formado ahí
esa es la conclusión pero surge entonces
otra pregunta el material que las formó
como llegó ahí el material también tiene
que subir el potencial gravitatorio que
decimos por la respuesta es que no lo
sabemos no tenemos ni idea y es un
misterio que se abierta ahora ante
nuestros ojos gracias a este mapa
pero tenemos una hipótesis y esa
hipótesis la quiero compartir hoy aquí
con vosotros
es posible y esta es especulación
científica por el momento que conste es
posible que el espolón de cc.oo sea la
cúspide de una onda de una oscilación
que lleva recorriendo el disco de la vía
láctea desde hace millones de años y al
igual que una piedra cuando la tiras a
un estanque forma unas pequeñas son
donadas en el agua
de la misma forma estas oscilaciones
verticales del disco de la vía láctea
podrían tener las pistas de una
ancestral colisión cataclísmica con una
galaxia enana de nuestro entorno
hace unos años un grupo de astrofísicos
descubrió el corazón de una galaxia
enana saliendo del otro lado de la
nuestra
le hemos llamado la galaxia enana del
sagitario
las simulaciones numéricas de otro
equipo de investigación han podido
demostrar que la evolución de esta
galaxia implica que ella ha estado
golpeando una y otra y otra vez el disco
de la vía láctea ha hecho varios pases a
lo largo de miles de millones de años en
cada una de estas colisiones el gas de
esa pequeña galaxia y el gas de nuestra
vía láctea se ha comprimido y en ese
momento se forman siempre estrellas y lo
más interesante es que uno de estos
brotes estelares brotes de formación
estelar parece coincidir con una época
en la que nació nuestra estrella el sol
hace cuatro mil 700 millones de años
esto nos dice algo poderoso nos dice
algo sobre quiénes somos realmente
hacemos un mapa de la galaxia por esto
para saber quiénes somos y de dónde
venimos es posible que quizás la
geoquímica y la bioquímica de la tierra
sean el resultado de una larga cadena de
acontecimientos cósmicos como este es
posible que seamos el producto de la
fusión de dos galaxias
bueno todavía no lo sabemos pero por eso
hay que investigar dejad que haga
hincapié en lo increíble que es que el
ser humano sea capaz de hacer un mapa
que abarca miles de años luz sin salir
de nuestro sistema solar
hace no mucho intentábamos hacer mapas
de nuestro propio planeta y vamos
perfilando las costas de un mundo de
trazo intrincado difuso y si va
concretando ya un siglo antes de que
pudiéramos salir al espacio exterior
teníamos una idea bastante detallada de
qué aspecto tendría el planeta cuando
nominar y cuando lo miraremos desde
arriba ahora vemos cómo el mapa de la
vía láctea va concretando se se va
definiendo de alguna forma se puede
decir que estamos en la edad de oro de
la exploración galáctica es fácil ver la
belleza en todo esto bueno al menos a mí
me parece bonito
pero es normal que surja la pregunta y
para qué sirve para qué sirve financiar
una misión espacial que lo único que
hace es medir distancias a estrellas
cuando tenemos problemas muy importantes
aquí abajo en la tierra y la verdad es
que los científicos que muchos están
cansados de ver está esta pregunta igual
responderán de una forma pasivo agresiva
con otra pregunta ellos dirán entonces
para que financiar la cultura para que
refinanciar con dinero público una
galería de arte o un teatro tampoco es
que resuelvan crisis humanitarias para
mí esta respuesta siempre me ha
desagradado no me parece
me parece muy convincente sinceramente
una forma de atenuar esta sensación de
derroche que hay con la ciencia es por
ejemplo mencionar que una misión
espacial como gaia le ha costado a cada
ciudadano europeo tan sólo 30 céntimos
al año durante 5 años sólo esos 30
céntimos al año
la verdad es que conectar los resultados
de la astrofísica a la sociedad es
francamente complicado pero no porque
esos resultados no estén ahí sino porque
a menudo
no serán en el corto plazo no se
presentan
la ciencia al final es un viaje a lo
desconocido y es precisamente por eso
porque desconocemos lo que vamos a
encontrar que no sabemos predecir cuál
es el riesgo de una inversión en ciencia
para que os hagáis una idea la nasa por
cada dólar que se ha invertido en ella
la economía estadounidense ha sido
retribuida con siete dólares en realidad
es un fondo de bajo riesgo y de
y de muchos éxitos la astronomía no es
sólo un compendio de curiosidades es
algo que forma parte de nuestro acervo
cultural es un derecho que debemos
defender para todos y para todas
yo no sé qué es resultados prácticos
traer a este mapa estelar que hemos
hecho pero sí que lo hará eventualmente
lo hará y sé que cuando una persona es
capaz de tener un mínimo sentido de la
escala con estas cosas cuando uno
reconoce a su mundo como un grano de
polvo perdido a la deriva en la
oscuridad cósmica o ve que su estrella
es nuestro sol es una cualquiera de
cientos de miles de millones
los problemas de la vida se tienden a
relativizar adquirimos una nueva
perspectiva y es una que infunde
humildad que nos hace muy pequeños pero
que por otra parte nos concede el honor
y la gloria de ser espectadores de esta
grandeza
jamás nadie verá la vía láctea desde
arriba eso es lo más probable pero
podemos hacer un mapa y podemos cambiar
de perspectiva a voluntad y es en esos
cambios de perspectiva donde creo que la
ciencia además de la humildad nos puede
enseñar lo que es la empatía la
capacidad de cambiar de punto de vista y
reconocer otros que son ajenos a nuestra
nuestra experiencia
saber que somos primos lejanos de los
hongos o que somos una colonia celular
altamente interdependiente una galaxia
de organismos saber que una máquina
puede aprender sola a pensar una
computadora con inteligencia artificial
o saber que la luna es un pedazo de
nuestro planeta que fue arrancado
violentamente en el pasado todas esas
cosas nos dicen quiénes somos
la ciencia ataque a nuestras ideas
preconcebidas en ocasiones sabemos como
una amenaza porque no le importa tocar
temas tabú y eso es porque está
precisamente diseñada para atacar los
cimientos del edificio de nuestras
creencias más arraigadas
a menudo se trata de superar nuestros
sesgos y no de validar los de entender
cuestiones como que la materia por sí
sola y siguiendo unas reglas sencillas
es capaz de organizar la complejidad la
belleza y el aparente diseño que
observamos en el universo a pesar de que
lo hace sin planificación sin
conocimiento de conjunto y sin voluntad
darnos cuenta que somos huérfanos en un
universo desprovisto de un propósito o
de un fin para operar puede resultar
angustioso para muchos es angustioso
pero es una revelación profunda que nos
dice que el significado de la vida solo
se lo podemos dar las personas
es un llamamiento a la militancia es un
ejercicio de madurez colectiva que pone
el peso de las responsabilidades de
nuestra existencia sobre los hombros de
la propia humanidad
en realidad hacemos un mapa galáctico
porque eso nos hace más humanos con
nuestros dos ojos pudimos triangular la
distancia a la rama de un árbol cercano
y con eso tuvimos la confianza para
agarrarla para no caer al suelo oscuro
de la selva
con los ojos de gaia nuestro nuestra
especie se proyecta hacia la galaxia
extendemos nuestros brazos hacia las
estrellas
[Aplausos]